it's one thing to be an NWA one thing to
go off on a solo career John Singleton
the filmmaker yes decides to put you yes
in boys in the hood yes
now was this something you ever believed
in your lifetime that you could have a
movie career not at all
I had a single to know that Ice Cube
could be good in a movie he was an
intern at the Arsenio Hall Show really
yeah I was up there because I wanted to
talk you know I was up there to talk to
our scene you know because I wanted him
to have you know easy and NWA on because
he had just had Luke 2 Live Crew's I'm
like dude if you can have them doing pop
that cootchie have us doing when I
express yourself so here come John
Singleton you know he's like an intern
intern oh you're cute yeah yeah what's
up man watch out what's up you know and
he's like yo man you know look I'm a
junior at USC right and you perfect for
my move [ __ ] off
I was this close to it but he was so
cool and he was helping me navigate
through you know trying to get to our
city yeah I was like oh he comes past
here and I could talk to him
you stay yeah yeah so we get to talk and
he's telling me about this script and
I'm like do whatever so that's what he
told you the script and you're hearing
it from an intern at the Arsenio Show
are you like this is such a shitty
script no I'm like dude I just don't
believe him right I'm essentially it
sounds irresponsible to even bring it up
yeah it's like one your junior USC you
don't have a movie I'm not even an actor
perfect we both we all crazy
so everyone associated with this is not
everybody what made you do it
I mean what his persistence really I've
seen him a year later he ran up dude hey
remember me like know who are you oh
yeah you know the Arsenio Hall Show I'm
a senior now and look perfect
so really how did how does he close the
deal with you because you're a pretty
successful artist at this point you got
solo career you had NWA but but no
you've never been in a movie
no well here's what happened you know my
manager tells me one day somebody want
to put you in a movie I have forgot
about this dude I mean I'm like of
course laser focused on my career and
I'm like I want to put me in a movie yes
might wanna put you in a movie I'm like
all right cool
give me the size and give me the script
right she gave me the script through the
script in my back seat took the sides
put them in the pocket and rolled out so
I went to the audition so I know who
these people were
I walk in and it's him like damn you you
know it's some production them like damn
you was it was really you wasn't
bullshitting he's like yeah man I
graduated and you perfect for my movie
right I auditioned I'm terrible I mean I
sit up right I think weird the script I
didn't read the sides I suck and he's
worried he's like oh [ __ ] so he said
look man did you read my script I said
not in and he said look at you one more
shot you go home read my script and when
you come back if you give you good
you're good if not I'm gonna have to
cast somebody else in your role so I
went and read the script and then you
know I had this epiphany like oh right
this is about our neighborhood this is
something I know I can do yes so when I
went back in I took it serious from then
on from that day on I've been taking
filmmaking and auditioning and acting
serious did you ever take a formal
lesson in acting ever since you've you
know gone into the acting field did you
ever go to a coach of any kind or did
you say to yourself that'll actually
screw me because I seem to have some
sort of natural ability here that could
really get messed up well when I was
filming boys in the hood
iin dedup like having to go like film 12
hours and then go they wanted me to see
this coach afterwards mm-hmm
I was like burn go act some more I don't
want to be myself now
yeah you want to get out of character
you know so Laurence Fishburne it was
like were you going I'm like man I just
gotta go just I went two days I it was I
hated it but I'm now got to go to this
damn class he's like for what yeah I
like tell John that he's like man [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
don't go he said me you know the role
you know who Doughboy is I say yeah he
said learn will Doughboy is and [ __ ]
stand and deliver